[Music]
good morning Hank it's Friday
[Applause]
thank you just been greeted by
nerdfighters in Richmond Virginia which
at least for a few hours last night was
the capital not only of the former
Confederacy but also the world capital
of nerdfighter Stan nerdfighter land
nerdfighteria I don't know let's leave
it for the nerdfighters to decide anyway
I had a great time in Richmond Virginia
I got to talk a lot about Walt Whitman I
met a bunch of nerdfighters who were
doing a lot of cool
clever nerd fighting I even got to see a
finger puppet theater rendition of the
talk the Yeti and I had when I was
telling her about the Boston Karki
fiasco with them from the 2.0
doppelganger in my face that's actually
a pretty good representation of how the
actual conversation went with the main
differences being hey I am NOT a green
lion be the actual conversation occurred
at 5:15 in the morning and see 5:15 in
the morning is not the ideal time to
give a Yeti bad news somehow because you
may or may not know I have all of these
extravagant rituals that surround flying
on airplanes that I use to keep the
airplane from you know crashing for
instance if I don't say the Lord's
Prayer both when the plane is taking off
and when the plane is landing it might
crash also if I do not touch the outside
of the plane while I am boarding it did
my crash furthermore while I am in the
airport before I board the plane I have
to purchase something that textually
discusses the commission of actual true
crimes
now think I know this stuff might sound
pretty crazy but the results of it are
pretty excellent so far I mean I've been
on 500 don't talk to me about security
right now I'm trying to do my videos I
mean I've been on like 500 flights since
I started all of these superstitions and
not one of them has landed prematurely
by the way Hank do you know what I knew
I wanted to marry Sarah it was when she
told me about this book that she wrote
when she was a kid that was about a
plane crash and you know what it was
called Thorntons unscheduled landing
anyway Hank all that stuff about
superstitions is a lead-up to this so
when I was in the airport in Richmond
Virginia I had to purchase like a
newspaper or a magazine
or something that discussed crime and I
happened to come across the Wall Street
Journal now Hank usually I don't buy The
Wall Street Journal on account of how
it's being purchased by Rupert I
maintain my youthful countenance by
drinking the blood of nerdfighters
Murdoch but I have to say even though
Rupert Murdoch built his media empire
primarily by devouring the freedom and
opportunity that have been the glory of
our nation's past the Wall Street
Journal is kind of a good newspaper so
Hank I'm just scanning The Wall Street
Journal to make sure that there's a
crime somewhere on the front page and oh
my god it's Daniel Biss Daniel Biss is
in The Wall Street Journal today talking
about all the money that he's raised
online and they talked about us too
since we helped him raise that money I
mean Hank that Hank is you Hank this
means that Brotherhood 2.0 contributed
in some small way to Daniel Biss a
progressive candidate being featured on
the front page of a newspaper that is
not noted for its liberal bias
nerdfighter evangelism is working Hank
we may be 3/4 done but nerdfighting is
just getting started
onward nerdfighter soldiers onward Hank
I apologize for all the background noise
and I'll see you on Monday